dans les RER les métros un trafic très
perturbé cinq lignes fermées et un
trafic très perturbé sur le RER la
perspective d'un jeu dinoir dans les
transports en commun assemblent-ils
découragé nombre de Franciliens de les
emprunter j'ai entendu que le mot
d'ordre de cette grève pour la RATP
c'était 0 métro zéro RER je prolongerai
en disant que c'est aussi 0 empathie
pour tous les Français à qui je pense
aujourd'hui qui ont pas pu aller
travailler
oh mon dieu ça explose
plusieurs explosions retentissent sur ce
site sensible placé ses vaisseaux une
usine de produits chimiques du groupe
Arkema situé près de Grenoble en pleine
partie de pêche au large de la
Nouvelle-Zélande ses marins ont eu la
surprise de voir débarquer sur l'avant
de leur bateau un requin non pas marteau
mais Mako ce squale réputé pour sauter
jusqu'à 6 mètres hors de l'eau a pu être
filmé par l'un des marins l'accident qui
a provoqué l'explosion n'a pas
occasionné de pollution ni fait de
blesser parmi les employés de l'usine le
bateau doit débarquer dans le port le
plus proche le pont le plus proche est
un port italien donc il faut que les
Italiens respectent la règle européenne
qui vient d'être rappelée il y a un
devoir légal et moral de sauver des vies
en mer
il y a une obligation légale pour les
pays membres d'agir selon les lois
internationales indépendamment des
raisons qui ont poussé ces gens à être
en détresse en mer si on remet en cause
le principe du port sur le plus proche
on va au devant le centaines ou de
milliers de situations de graves
d'enjeux humanitaires la situation à
bord commençait à devenir très
préoccupante avec 234 migrants dont 57
enfants qui depuis près de 20 jours
attendent de débarquer à tel point que
ce matin quatre personnes ont été
élittriées jusqu'à l'hôpital de Bastia
face à cette situation
les autorités françaises ont pris la
décision à titre exceptionnel de palier
au comportement inacceptable du
gouvernement italien et d'inviter le
navire à rejoindre le port militaire de
Toulon l'accueil de ce bateau va ouvrir
un dangereux précédent qui va conduire
la France à accueillir d'autres l'Italie
fait preuve d'une nouvelle fermeté et on
peut comprendre l'Italie quand il y a
234 personnes comme ça à bord d'un
navire il s'agit pas d'en faire un
symbole et en faire le symbole de la
fermeté mais de se demander comment on
accueille des gens dignement et qui
puissent
survivre là ça veut dire en d'autres
termes que la politique d'immigration de
la France ne se décide plus depuis le
ministère de l'Intérieur à Paris mais en
réalité depuis la mer par les ONG
que c'est de la détresse organisée
organisé par un consortium de passeur et
de fausses organisations humanitaires
pardon SOS Méditerranée c'est des
subventions de ville de France écolo
également de l'Open Society de George
Soreau avisé internationaliste donc ils
savent ce qu'ils veulent ils vont
chercher ces ONG ces bateaux de migrants
à 20 ou 30 km des côtes libyennes ou des
côtes tunisiens
c'est bateau de migrants devraient être
raccompagnés dans les portes de départ
c'est à dire généralement dans les
sports de sous ou dans les portes de
Sfax ils ne pourront pas sortir du
centre administratif où on va les mettre
ils ne sont donc pas légalement sur le
territoire national ils ne sont donc pas
sur notre territoire national au sens
juridique du terme d'abord un examen
médical puis un examen avec la DGSI pour
voir s'il y a évidemment pas de
personnes dangereuses parmi ces
personnes puis ensuite un entretien pour
savoir s'ils sont éligibles à l'asile le
principe de base devrait je le rappelle
que quand les migrants sont
il y a quelques kilomètres des côtes
africaines il faut qu'elle revienne vers
le port d'attache il y a déjà deux tiers
de ces deux 34 personnes qui ont dans
d'autres pays neuf pays ont déjà accepté
en européen de les accueillir nous les
remercions et puis tous ceux qui ne
pourront pas avoir l'asile repartiront
directement dans leur pays d'origine
tout n'est pas donc perdu dans ce pays
Michel Sardou remontera sur scène Sardou
le retour les autorités italiennes ont
été par ailleurs non professionnels
elles ont laissé pendant 20 jours sans
décision ce bateau et il y aura
évidemment un certain nombre de
conséquences déjà 500 policiers français
sont en la frontière italienne pour
pouvoir mieux contrôler notre frontières
et on a refusé la relocalisation des
3500 migrants que nous devions à
l'Italie